Some Superheroes and their powers are integral
to ensuring the world will continue rotating
while also keeping citizens safe from all
of the supervillains who are always trying
to stir up some trouble.
These Superheroes usually possess one or a
few effective powers and the ability to utilize
them in just the right way.
However, not all powers superheroes were given
are equally handy.
With so many heroes and even more powers,
it almost seems unavoidable to have a few
pointless and often laughable abilities.
Be prepared to be perplexed with 10 Completely
Useless Superhero Powers.
Archery
An aptitude for archery may be enough to beef
up someone’s application to Harvard or to
impress someone on their first date but for
a super power, it is a bit of a yawn.
Hawkeye and the Green Arrow share this rather
useless superpower with little else to assist
them in fighting evil.
Lucky for them, they have friends with much
more impressive superpowers.
Sure, arrows can slow someone down, but is
it really going to do as much damage as almost
any other weapon- based power?
Not so much.
Unless these superheroes are planning on entering
The Hunger Games, they should probably let
the real superheroes do their jobs.
Even as Hunger Games tributes, they may be
less skilled at Archery than Katniss who never
claims Archery is a superpower, she just happens
to be good at it.
Power Ring
When wearing the ring, the superhero has numerous
abilities proving to be the most practical
accessory for anyone trying to save the world
There is a major problem with this superpower,
since the power comes from the ring itself,
it can be attained by anyone who is sneaky
enough to sneak it off the fingers of the
likes of The Green Lantern and The Wonder
Twins, rendering the heroes useless.
No matter how much can be gained from adorning
any power accessory, the likelihood of losing
or being separated from it, makes it a bit
of a risky power.
Cryokinesis
There is nothing chilling about contending
with a superhero with the power of Cryokinesis.
The only ones who know how to use Cryokinese,
the ability to control the cold, effectively
are the villains.
While Killer Frost freezes her victims with
a kiss and Captain Cold can wreak havoc on
entire downs paralyzing countless people with
his Icy antics, the heroes seem to only be
equipped with the less than exciting cryokinesis
powers.
Captain Planet can generate ice but so can
a working freezer.
Aquaman’s unnecessary sidekick, Aqualad
can generate cold energy from his hands but
so can a lot of grandmothers.
Cryokinesis is a decent superpower for villains
but for superheroes, it is just not cool.
Enhanced Sight:
If enhanced sight seems like an indispensable
power, try telling that to Daredevil.
Hawkeye has keen eyesight but seems to have
issues with seeing things right in front of
him.
Wolverine also has enhanced vision, but he
also has superhuman healing and retractable
bone claws so who cares if he excels reading
an eye chart.
For superheroes with additional powers, exceptional
vision will not increase their odds of defeating
their enemies.
Enhanced sight is mostly useless because there
is rarely an instance where it is an essential
resource that could not easily be replaced
with a pair of good quality binoculars.
Chlorokinesis:
Chlorokinesis is the ability to control plants
with your mind.
Captain Planet uses it for good, Poison Ivy
uses it for evil and Groot uses it to grow
himself an entire forest but he is a plant
so it seems fair and much more desirable for
his situation.
Guaranteeing oxygen and vegetation on earth
without using water or depending on the elements
may be the best use of Chlorokinesis.
While it may be beneficial to understand the
inner workings of nature and even be capable
of telling them what to do and when to grow,
it is not an especially useful power.
However, Chlorokinesis may have helped out
the characters from The Happening.
Danger Sense:
Knowing when danger is near is not exactly
the most difficult exercise in intuition,
so while Peter Parker’s Spider Sense is
tingling, the use of other superpowers are
getting things done.
Elektra uses her danger sense to get better
use of her super stealth, but considering
her martial arts capability and weapon skills,
showing up late to the party would not be
a major complication.
The danger sense is also redundant for those
with the natural ability to be aware of their
surroundings.
Being ultra-aware of trouble looming certainly
allows superheroes the advantage of not being
blindsided but in the end, danger sense is
the alarm to the stolen car that is already
halfway down the street.
Elasticity:
Being ultra-flexible has plenty of advantages
like being able to show off your talent at
your yoga class, or getting a prime spot as
a contortionist for the circus, but to call
it a superpower is a bit of a stretch.
To be fair, elasticity is a bit more than
just flexibility, it usually involves the
hero’s body to form and stretch their body
beyond normal human capability.
There may be occasional benefits of being
able to get between tight spots and reach
the top shelf, but that is not saying much.
Elastigirl and Mr. Fantastic use their powers
to expand, give themselves extra reach and
even take a hit like a champ, but even with
their knack for making the best out of a less
than thrilling superpower, it can’t feel
especially ego boosting to be a walking, talking
Stretch Armstrong.
Power Absorption-
Initially, the power of absorption may seem
pretty great when coming in contact with superheroes
and supervillains who possess a power you
want, but if that is a hero’s only ability,
they may not want to run into a disgruntled
Batman in a dark alley as Bruce Wayne has
no superheroes to steal.
Rogue’s absorption powers would be considered
an exception to this typically useless ability
as she can absorb a person’s memories, talents,
and energy whether they are superhuman or
not.
In most scenarios, power absorption is not
an ideal power even more so when considering
all of the other terrible abilities out there
that could be absorbed.
Precognition:
Knowing the future may be appealing for some
but terrifying for others.
Captain Marvel and Psylocke have this ability
but considering their other many much more
valuable powers, it is mostly just a nuisance.
This ability typically comes in the form of
a dream, or may be ignited by seeing or touching
something.
In theory, the power could be useful but it
typically backfires creating, even more, problems.
Seeing the future only causes a hero to attempt
to change the outcome of events which may
be impossible or changed resulting in a butterfly
effect causing even more of a disaster.
The worst aspect of precognition is the vision
is rarely clear and more of a confusing mess
of images that most likely means something
completely different than the hero originally
understood which was proven the case in the
season 3 finale of Agents of Shield after
a seemingly homeless man with his own precognition
provided Daisy with momentary precognition.
Omnilingualism:
Having the ability to speak any language no
matter how rare and the ability to communicate
with every person not just on Earth but the
entire Universe would be a pretty nifty gift
for us boring humans, but for superhumans,
it is a bit of a disappointment.
For Dr. Manhattan, omnilingualism is just
one of his many powers and for DC’s Starfire,
it would barely even be worth mentioning on
her resume considering she can fly.
The handiest use of Omnilinguilasm may have
been Glory from Buffy the Vampire Slayer as
she was able to speak to humans and every
specie and sub-specie of demon.
However, such a power was still low on her
list of exceptional skills.
When you consider that a majority of the power
could easily be duplicated with a few phone
Apps, the power is fairly useless.
There are many more useless superpowers out
there, which one did we forget?
Which powers have you chuckling to yourself
or just leave you scratching your head?
Let us know in the comments!
While you’re at it, you can also like, share,
subscribe and watch all of our videos.